Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated here
on the Rich Eisen show what happens with
Anthony Davis is gonna be paramount and
he essentially said on NBA TV could be
anybody
then everybody's on his list except New
Orleans right now and that anything can
possibly happen the only thing that we
know for sure is he's out of New Orleans
and when he does it's gonna be very nice
Instagram farewell as well across this
basically is what he said that's that's
that's big in the 20% yes was Davis dick
Davis did double back rich on on and
said all 29 teams but I took his
original comments that he said to the
assembled media that Boston was on the
list as being closer to the truth only
because you know being around the
organization a lot the suburbs have
always been pretty confident that if
they retain Kyrie Irving that Anthony
Davis is gonna want to play that now
Kyrie goes they may not even make a full
fledged pitch to Anthony Davis for
Anthony Davis because that won't be the
direction the team wants to go but if
they can retain Kyrie they've always
been really confident and they've done a
lot of research on this guy over the
last 18 months they've always been
really confident that Anthony Davis
wants to play with Kyrie Irving and
wants to play for a winner in Boston
offers both well and so I mean let's
just say something like that happens I
mean but why was Dell Demps fired Chris
I mean how is this his fault how could
how is this laid at his feet right now
I mean look the the current situation
maybe not Dell but remember he's been
there for like seven eight years and you
know for the entire Anthony Davis tenure
and he's traded away draft picks he's
made some bad draft picks he's made some
bad contract signings
I mean I don't know the Dells you know
that this was a you know at Anthony
Davis and his team led effort to kind of
force this this whole mess that turned
out to be but up until this point the
reason asked me Davis or bakeries
Anthony Davis wants out is because this
team is not they haven't built a winner
around it and and that that to me was
was the big reason why Dell was let go
and I look I said this weeks ago that if
you're gonna create Anthony Davis you
can either have to commit to Dell Demps
or find somebody else because you do not
want somebody making a
Herschel Walker type a deal that could
read up your franchise or screw it up
forever you don't want that person to be
a temporary guy yeah I mean but who's
gonna say raise their hand and say I'll
take the job trading Anthony Davis and
and then deal with though I I think I
think it'll be a lot of people rich you
do I really need to be a lot of people
because this lookey you know on the
surface it's not a great job but I made
the Herschel Walker no comparison look
what the Dallas Cowboys turns out to be
after making that deal I mean you are
you're going to get back the most
substantial trade package NBA history
the least good in terms of players draft
picks cap relief you're gonna have a
chance to revamp your team with the
assets Andrew gave us gets the point
where at this pelicans game if this
deals done right they could be in the
playoffs in a couple of years and they
could be trending towards a winning
situation in a few years so I think if
God's a lot more appealing than people
think ok and do you think they end up
getting a better deal than the one that
the Lakers put on the table if they
don't they'll get the exact same deal
the Lakers aren't gonna you know screw
around with this and if they think
Boston's out look I mean look at what
could happen before a Laker deal gets
consummated what a Kawhi Leonard decides
to stay in Toronto is that going to
embolden another team can he beat
Chicago you know Anthony Davis is from
the area maybe Chicago says look we'll
put Lowry market in and Chris Dunn and a
few graphics into it don't want it you
don't want to roll the dice if you're
the Lakers so at a bare minimum rich
yeah I think it's going to be the exact
same offer if not stronger get the
pelicans player right so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience